[Music]
foreign
this is uh this is gonna be a good one
actually I don't I don't think that I
would have necessarily thought to do
this topic on my own but uh we had a
listener we had a listener named Celtic
Angel 73 who gave us this topic idea and
actually even gave me some ideas for
like the people to cover on here I'm not
I'm doing you know how I do I initially
had because I was trying to like pick
out different ones because like the
topic is like people who survived
horrific events right and um I had of
course like five or six of them and then
like earlier today like on my lunch hour
I was going through my notes and I was
like okay I'm taking some of these out
because it's like this is going to take
forever so I'm just gonna go down to
three that I thought were like the
coolest two of them were ones that
Celtic Angel recommended and actually
I'm really interested that would it stop
what are you doing I turned it off okay
that's I can't do that you just it was
your accident you destroyed it was an
accident
[Laughter]
yeah uh and then I forgot what I was
saying I forgot what I was saying Celtic
Angel yeah yeah yeah two of them are one
that yeah and neither of them uh were
cases that I had heard of before and
it's really weird because both of them
were like pretty [__] horrific
especially the first one I want to talk
about which is apparently like a really
really famous case from like the early
1960s but I had never heard about it and
it's [__] crazy so I'm actually
really glad uh that Celtic Angel 73 like
recommended these because like I said I
don't know if I would have necessarily
found these cases on my own but yeah so
that it's so should be fun like I said
these were like three really cool cases
of surviving uh [__] that probably
shouldn't have survived yeah I don't
know which ones they are yeah I don't
know which one I mean like I said there
was like some that I was thinking about
I said oh maybe we could do one about um
Aaron Ralston like that guy that was
hiking and like got his arm caught under
a rock and I had to cut his hand off but
then I was like yeah but they were made
a movie about that and everybody kind of
knows about that stewardess that fell
out of the airplane lived
um I was gonna do that one but I didn't
but because I have another one of a
woman that fell out of a plane and lived
I didn't want to do both of them okay
you know what I mean but I did have that
originally
um one of those is in here
what do you mean said you have one yeah
yeah yeah yeah one of them is in there
okay yeah but not the stewardess okay
it's a different one yeah but it was
like a different eye case it's still
falling out still falling out of a
[__] airplane and I well here's the
thing I don't want it this isn't like a
competition like between like who
survived more [__] up [__] but I
thought because the stewardess well you
know the air hose whatever they call
them now it's a stewardess um she was
like um
God damn it she uh I forgot what I was
gonna say
never mind I'm sure you were saying you
were saying how bad it was
and but then the stewardess won I don't
know what you're you're gonna make some
kind of comparison between oh okay so
yeah so the one that she yes she fell
out of a plane and [__] like that and
survived but this other woman that fell
out of a plane and survived she also was
stranded in the Peruvian jungle for 11
days until something I think I know
which one you talk about so uh so I was
like okay I think that edges that out a
little bit
I think I know like I said it's not it's
not a competition like like who had more
[__] up [__] happened to them because
this is like pretty [__] up [__] and
it's like
I watched um like some documentaries
about some of these and like they're
really
it's horrifying like to listen to but
they're actually really inspiring too
because just like holy crap I can't
imagine like what these people
were going through like the whole time
that this [__] was going on I'm just
like geez you're just trying to survive
it I guess yeah and it's like God damn a
lot of times when you're going through
bad [__] you don't have time to think
about it
well motorcycle wrecks and [__] and
[__] nearly freezing to death and
near-death experiences it happened so
fast you're so focused in on what the
hell is going on right there at that
particular moment you're not even afraid
well I kind of feel like these people in
particular uh these particular three
cases that I'm gonna talk about
um they had plenty of time to think
about it to think about the [__] which
is I think what made it like seem a lot
more horrible to me you know what I mean
like maybe they didn't remember because
I kind of feel like like the woman that
fell out of the plane like um that she
didn't really remember the exact thing
that happened but you know what I mean
but it's still like enduring [__] that
happened like afterward yeah Celtic
Angel 73 said hello I'm excited that you
guys used my suggestion it was a really
really good suggestion and uh especially
the first one that I'm going to talk
about because this was a [__] amazing
case and I can't believe I never heard
about it because it's not only somebody
that survived
like a horrific thing but it was also
kind of like a true crime and it's like
murder and [__] like that because they
thought it was one thing but now it's
like it turned out it was something else
and it's just like a [__] crazy story
it's a crazy [__] story
but yeah so
um I don't know like if you have
anything that you would like to
go into I'm ready
you're ready I'm ready
[Laughter]
yeah we spent the last night last night
in today's bet cleaning the house you
know yep and uh roof is in it did the
roof this morning yeah and they finished
the roof yeah they got it done in only a
few hours they got the second they did
the top they finished that all we had to
do is just do the uh the little things
that run around the outside of the house
and that didn't take them very long four
hours maybe yeah because when I got home
from work they were they had left or
yeah they were still here when I got
here yesterday it's done got it done
hooray they bent one of the gutters
though they're gonna come back and fix
it well they better yeah throwing [__]
off the side or something fell off the
side bit one of the gutters God damn
uh let's see Victor says hey I made it I
set an alarm
[Laughter]
then Trey said YouTube YouTube is acting
weird tonight I hope not
um let's see off topic have you thought
about covering the 1957 classic 12 Angry
Men excellent movie ooh that is an
excellent movie and I actually haven't
seen that in a really long time yeah
maybe we'll get around to it
Victor said my solar panels went live
today solar panels yeah
[Laughter]
you guys said snake Handler and Atlanta
zoo got bitten by a black mamba luckily
the largest hospital in the state is
about 10 minutes away and they had
anti-ben and that's well that's good
Jesus Christ let's hope they keep that
[__] on side you know it's weird I keep
um because on my way to work I go
through DeLand
and there's a serpentarium and I can't
believe it's still there like I used to
go there all the time like when I lived
in Daytona and it's not big but it's
like they have all different kind of
snakes and they have a guy like a snake
Handler essentially not like you know
the religious kind but he just comes out
and talks about all the snakes and he's
been bit like a whole bunch of times too
like his hands were just like scar
tissue like all over
um let's see some guys have been bitten
so many times these little bitty drops
that they're kind of immune to it yeah
well I feel like this guy I mean he'd
been bitten by like pretty much every
venomous snake
I think that one guy I think one guy
claimed his own his hands just looked
like [__] gnarled up [__] Roots
all right
from all those little Nicks and snake
bites that he had handling those things
and a bunch of different ones
one time he got a full-on bite from I
think it was a diamondback rattlesnake
and he shook it off like it didn't
happen
so he was kind of immune to it yeah
telling that snake he's like you're a
[__] yeah that's what he claimed I
don't know right that was on TV a long
time ago that was back before you could
check
so yeah because he could have been like
I've been [__] and spin in the yarn
yeah saying all kind of like crazy [__]
yeah
granther says uh grandfather had a few
close calls over the years it still
makes me laugh that you refer to
yourself to the third person uh bullets
were flying blood and teeth were on the
ground but sweet Jesus let me live to
see another morning
that's the thing some people just get
lucky or unlucky as the case may be like
I said I'm not really sure
these three cases I'm not really sure if
I'd call it lucky or unlucky but you
know
they they seem to have like uh you know
made peace with what happened you know
what I'm saying
but yeah so uh you want to get into it
or all right because uh oh Victor said
my cousin got bit in her hand by a
rattlesnake when she was seven holy [__]
yeah there's a lot of rattlesnakes
around here and those little what are
those little pygmy Rattlers yeah my
brother caught one of those in a bucket
one time when I was a kid
he didn't bite them now
all right so uh the first case that we
want to talk about this [__] is crazy
and I can't believe I never heard about
it
so this happened in 1961.
and this is the case of Terry Joe I
think it's duperalt or dupero I'm not
really sure
um she's from Wisconsin
so I'm not sure if you pronounce her
name like the Frenchie way or just like
the Americanized way
so what ended up happening with this and
as I said it was super super famous at
the time I mean obviously I wasn't born
in 1961 but apparently this was a big
deal and I love like um some
documentaries that I watched about it
like some people that were alive at the
time were like oh my God I remember like
this big deal it was on the cover of
Life magazine and everything
and the picture that was on the cover of
Life magazine
was of this little girl sitting in a
little bitty kind of like a Lifeboat but
I kind of feel like I've seen different
documentaries that said it wasn't
actually exactly a Lifeboat it's kind of
a Lifeboat boat but it was kind of more
like a float like it was made of cork it
was kind of shaped like an oval like
that and then it had like kind of
netting at the bottom
so she was just like sitting in that in
the middle of the [__] ocean and
apparently like these guys on this
freighter ship had like found her like
Against All Odds which we'll get into
and had taken a picture of her because
they're like holy [__] [__] like
there's this little girl like out in the
middle of the [__] ocean and they uh
Sunbird as hell she was yeah yeah she
was and she was uh really dehydrated and
she was starting to hallucinate and all
this other kind of stuff how old was she
good 11. all right she was 11 years old
and uh so at first they thought as you
would that this little girl
um you know oh maybe she'd been on a
ship with her family or whatever and the
ship sank and she was like the only one
that survived and
technically I guess that's true but not
exactly because all kind of [__]
crazy ass [__] went on before and this
this is a horrible horrible story
so what ends up happening so they so
they you know saved a little girl and
it's like for a long time she wouldn't
talk she was kind of like freaked out
but finally they got like the story out
of her Sorry my phone's ringing and it's
like really distracting it's like just
shut up
I thought it was awesome
non-profit it says
well you gotta plug it back in because
it's otherwise it's not going to charge
so uh so yeah so she wouldn't talk at
first because she was like really scared
and freaked out and everything like that
but when they finally got the story out
of her this is what happened so as I
said this happened in 1961.
now there was an optometrist named Dr
Arthur duperault and he was from Green
Bay Wisconsin
and uh this was Terry Joe's dad
uh he also had a wife named Gene and two
other kids Brian who was 14 and Renee
who was seven and as I mentioned Terry
Jo was 11 years old
now his big dream was he wanted to
get like a ship or like a yacht and
because he was real into that and he
wanted to take his family on a sailing
trip like around the world like for a
year
so he's like well let's do kind of like
a trial run for that because it's like I
want to see if you guys you know
actually would enjoy that or you know
whatever
so they decide to take a seven day trip
in the Bahamas
so they Charter a yacht called the
Bluebell and they sailed out of Fort
Lauderdale so like I said it was the dad
and the mom and the three kids and they
also brought along like for help
um Dr duperault's friend uh who was a
former Marine and a World War II veteran
his name was Julian Harvey and he was
like a skipper Captain type of thing
so he came along and he also brought his
new wife with him whose name was Mary
and they had been married for only about
three or four months at this point
so basically uh for the first four or
five days of the trip everything seemed
totally fine you know families are
getting along they're having a good time
the family is having a really good time
they're like oh my God I can't wait to
you know to do this again or to like go
on this trip around the world or
whatever that they were planning
but then on about the fifth night of the
cruise
Terry Joe the 11 year old said that she
was asleep in the cabin
and she got woken up by a bunch of
screaming and kind of like stamping
around or like you know somebody you
know stamping around on the deck
so she basically goes upstairs to see
what's going on
and said that she saw her mother and her
brother lying on the floor
dead and there was just blood everywhere
and she's like what the [__] is going on
pretty much and then she sees Julian
Harvey the skipper Captain Marine guy
like walking toward her and she's like
what happened you know as you would and
apparently he was carrying like a rifle
or something like that
and he just came to her and kind of like
shoved her back down in the cabin like
and just said you know just go back down
there
so she goes back to her room and she's
like freaking out she has no [__]
idea like what the hell is going on
she's like she'd seen her mother and her
brother there was blood everywhere she's
like she they looked like they were dead
she doesn't know where Dad is she
doesn't know where her little sister is
um you know the little sister would
normally be sleeping in the cabin with
her but she'd actually like stayed up uh
you know on the upper deck with the
adults so she didn't know where she was
either
so she's down there kind of like Frozen
in fear terrified and then water starts
coming into the cabin and like filling
it up
like up to the level of like the
mattress or something like that
so obviously she kind of like wigs out
again and she runs back up to the upper
deck and sees Julian Harvey up there and
is like is the boat sinking she said and
he goes yes
right he tells her that it's thinking
and then he's like okay well we need to
get in the dinghy like the Lifeboat or
whatever and so he gives her the Rope
like to hold on to it I guess like we're
both gonna get into it or something that
was kind of like what he told her and
she was kind of freaking out and she
dropped the rope and the dinghy kind of
started like floating away
so Julian jumps off the sinking boat and
like swims out after the dinghy leaving
the 11 year old girl just kind of like
standing there
so
I mean fair play to her she's 11 years
old the boat is sinking the skipper the
only person that she's seen alive just
jumped off the [__] boat and like
swam toward the dinghy like she's like
he's gonna leave her there
but she actually had the presence of
mind to think oh I think there was
another Lifeboat or another float or
something like that like she knew where
it was
so she went to get it and like I said it
was I don't you know it's hard to tell
from the pictures but it's really really
small it's only about like the length of
maybe like five or six feet and it was
just kind of like a long it looked like
it was made of like of white cork like
around the outside and then there was
like netting on the inside
so she found that and she managed to get
into it yeah it's basically like a no
the dinghy was oh okay the guy took that
okay he took the digging he went he swam
after it she was like I have to get the
life raft essentially
so she got on that she managed to get in
there
now she doesn't have any idea where the
rest of her family are she doesn't know
what the [__] is going on
so she goes out in the thing the ship
sinks
and she is out on the open ocean
for 84 hours 84 hours no water no food
no nothing
that's like almost four days five days
yeah four days yeah
yeah that's almost four days four days
yeah out in the middle of the [__]
ocean 11 years old no food no water so
this is nothing so we're what happened
to all the other people that were
supposed well now we're gonna find that
out now we're gonna find that okay
because that's the crazy part yeah this
is a murder went down and he was trying
to kill everybody and escape the boats
what he was trying to do that's the
crazy part all right I I see what
happened yeah I suspected it well don't
spoil it okay no there's only one
explanation
yeah so I'm just saying
so yeah she was out there for 84 hours
and she later on because she wrote a
book um I think in 2010
called alone
and um so what was it called like alone
like something about orphan the sea
orphan or something like that I can't
remember like what the what the subtitle
was
but yeah she was basically like out
there uh the and the the shitty thing
too was that the boat after she was out
there for like three days or whatever it
was just made of like shitty cork or
whatever and it was starting to
disintegrate so had the freighter ship
not happen to see her when they saw her
it's very likely that she probably would
have drowned or gotten eaten by a shark
or something like that she'd have died
um because they said by the time they
found her she was pretty [__] up like
her like she was completely sunburned
and you know really dehydrated stuff I
mean she completely recovered but yeah
she was like pretty messed up but they
said they didn't know how much longer
she didn't have water or anything did
you no no no yeah she she couldn't have
lasted another day or two no no there's
no way so it was like and it was just it
was really kind of like a miracle that
they saw her because they said the
[__] up thing and I think this might
have been I don't know if it was this
specific case but it was cases like this
that made it um kind of like uh where
they where they had the um the the
Lifeboat and stuff like that like be a
bright color like orange or something
because they said the thing about this
one was it was white and she was blonde
and she had like a white blouse and like
little pink pants and so like from the
you know from the a ship or a plane or
something like that you just look like a
little white cap like down in the water
they can't really see you yeah and she
said too like after they rescued her
that she'd been in the boat it was like
the second or third day and there was
like a little red you know twin engine
plane or whatever and it was like flying
around like circling her and she just
kept screaming and like waving at it and
it couldn't see her even though it
wasn't that high up because she it was
just like all white and that just looks
like little waves like you know so it's
kind of like I said a miracle that they
even saw her
so yeah so she was rescued after 84
hours
now when they found out what happened it
turned out that Julian Harvey the guy
that it's wearing for the dinghy he had
been rescued like I think
um a day or two prior to them finding
Terry Joe
his story was that the ship like he said
something about oh the masts had like
collapsed or something and the ship
started to sink and like oh everybody
um drowned you know excuse me everybody
drowned and all this other kind of stuff
and he's like I was the only one that
survived bloody blah yeah it sounds good
and uh when they told him they're like
Oh no you're not the only one that
survived um Terry Joe like the little
girl she survived and he reacted a
little bit strangely he reacted like oh
my God like oh that's awesome you know
what I mean you could tell he was
thinking like oh [__]
yeah
um and then a day or two after he found
out that Terry Jo had been found
they um they found his body in a hotel
room he had committed suicide he had
checked in under like a pseudonym
and left a note you know for a friend of
his and he had he committed suicide by
slight by taking a razor blade and
slicing his throat his ankle and his
wrists or something I mean he was like
serious about it
so what they found out later on
was that uh Julian Harvey had apparently
decided to use this particular Cruise
in order to kill his new wife Mary who'd
like I said they'd only been married for
three or four months damn he got sick of
her fast
that's well that's not what it was
insurance or some [__] yeah yeah uh she
had uh what was then like a very very
large insurance policy twenty thousand
dollars on her life and I mean that was
in 1961 that was a lot of money and uh
there was also a double indemnity clause
which means that if she died
um in an accident or murder as long as
it wasn't him that murdered her right
you know that's a little that's a little
detail there that maybe he should have
looked into uh then he would get double
the money
so what he was trying to do and I
neglected to mention that when they
found him in the dinghy he had his
wife's drowned body in the boat with him
and people were like well you know why
would he have that I'm like well because
like after he died and they looked into
his past and everything and they were
like oh
he apparently had kind of like a habit
of doing this Mary was his sixth wife
now not all of them had died I don't
think
but he did try to pull this kind of like
insurance scam before and I think there
was one I can't remember which wife it
was but he actually drove himself and
the wife and I think one other person
like off a [__] overpass like into a
river or something like that but he yeah
but he did it on purpose and like he
knew like how to get out of the car and
everything like that so he to collect
like some money on some life insurance
so it wasn't the first time that he did
that they didn't find that out until
later on though
so what they suspect happened was that
he was going to use this trip to kill
his wife and get the insurance money
and they suspect that probably uh Dr
duperol uh Terry Joe's dad probably saw
him do it at which point Julian Harvey
was like oh well I guess I have to kill
everybody now like to get away with it
but then he thought oh if I can get on
the dinghy and get back to civilization
then I can just say Oh Ship sunk and
everybody drowned too bad so sad
um hey hand over the money here's my
dead wife I even brought her and he
brought her in the Diggy I guess for
that particular proof she was doing to
prove that she was dead yeah because the
thing is it's like if she was just lost
at sea then it would might take like a
really long time to like you know to
prove that she was actually dead soon
she didn't want any so it's like he
dressed it's like [__] horrible man
that she was stinking too by the time he
did drought he did drown her but it's
like I guess but so the other people in
the family
were uh stabbed I think he stabbed him
which is crazy because I think that
Terry Joe said that he had a rifle so I
don't know why he wouldn't have shot
them but I guess he stabbed them
the weird thing about it though is that
there's been a lot of speculation about
why he didn't kill Terry Joe because he
very well could have
he did see her like because she came up
out of the out of the cabin and she was
like what's going on and he just
basically pushed her back down it's like
hey stay down there he didn't kill her
because she was no threat to him he
figured she'd just drown to see well he
killed the little the other little girl
and the 14 year old boy he killed them
yeah how did he do you stabbed him as
far as they know they've never found the
bodies
but they did um but Terry Joe said that
she did found a see a knife later on and
that there was blood everywhere like you
know what I mean they actually had to
like um because obviously she was very
traumatized by this incident because
like not only is she out in the [__]
middle of the ocean for four days with
no but her whole family got murdered
yeah like I can't imagine like Ugh she's
still alive she's you know because I saw
like an interview with her and stuff but
and she really um like I said she got
it took her a long time to like want to
talk about it but um you know she got
married and she did all the had some
kids and [__] like that and she seems to
have come to like a good place in her
life and she
she has a thing where she's kind of like
well you just have to like appreciate
every single day she seems very very
positive like to turn have turned it
into something positive but she said it
took her a really long time to get to
that point well I had when she was 10 11
yeah 11 yeah yeah but yeah so they're so
they're wondering like why did he leave
Terry Joe alive I thought it was because
because a lot of people are said oh well
maybe he like deep down wanted to get
caught I don't think that's the case I
think that
um because what happened was she said
that she had the Rope of the you know
the dinghy and dropped it and then like
the dinghy like went off like that so I
was thinking that he was like needed her
help like to get the Rope or whatever
and then when she dropped it he was like
man [__] her she'll probably die anyway
I think he was gonna take her on the
dinghy and then push her off and then
kill her later and then kill her later
yeah so I think it just kind of happened
that she dropped the rope and he was
just like oh [__] it she's probably dead
anyway because the boat's gonna sink and
she's not gonna survive out here so it's
like when they rescued him him like a
few days before they found her and he's
just thinking you know he already told
the cops his story oh the boat it's just
you know the the mass collapsed and you
know the boat sank and everybody died
and it was so sad and blah blah yeah and
those dudes know the sea like the back
of their hand and they're going Mass
collapse and what well that's what the
guy that like the guy who owned the boat
because it was a chartered boat was like
yeah that that's not that's not how that
works yeah oh you know what I mean so
they thought it was suspicious at first
but then when they found Terry Joe and
she told them what it really happened
um and the stories didn't match up they
were like oh okay so I guess this
[__] like murdered this whole
entire family Jesus Christ
um and I guess he knew he was busted
because I think it was only a day or two
later that they found his cut up ass in
the [__] and he if he was gonna kill
her on the boat
he that means that from from the very
beginning he had already figured out in
his mind that he was going to have to
kill everybody on a boat
yeah I mean that's the thing I didn't
know
because he you know he dies any other
way he died so they didn't ask him but
it's like I wondered if he was initially
planning to just
surreptitiously like push his wife
overboard and then go oh no you know
what I mean and then not have to kill
the whole entire family and I kind of
think that maybe he was in the process
of doing that and then he got seen and
then he was like well [__] now I have to
kill the whole entire family I don't
know if he was necessarily
gonna kill the whole entire family he
might have been I don't know maybe he
was just gonna kill the wife of the
throw overboard then throw her overboard
and then just say yeah that it was an
accident yeah you know what I mean but I
think he got spotted I don't think he
went out I mean like I said I don't know
and he died like right after and he
seems like a [__] crazy person to be
honest but I don't think he intended to
like kill the whole entire family I
think it was just because he got seen
and then he's like that's what I'm
saying not risk that's what I'm saying
yeah and the thing about it is like if
you were gonna do like maybe he wanted
like other witnesses around or something
like that because he's like look yeah
she's gone yeah if you're gonna bump off
your wife for the insurance money you'd
think that it's like why would you take
her like a bunch of
maybe he was drowning her in a bucket or
something a bucket of water he had
that's what I'm saying that's somebody
heard all that threats running around
by the time that they got to him she was
unconscious or dead really [__] head
in a damn bucket and he had to kill the
kill that guy and they had to you know
whoever it was that saw him and then he
had to go through and kill everybody one
by one he probably killed them kids
while they were in bed
that kind of stuff yeah
that's it's just [__] up man that's
[__] up
yeah that's a crazy [__] story oh
yeah
that dude needs to be stomped into a
greasy spot well he already took himself
out of here out of the human race well
yeah that's what a lot of the comments
said like afterwards it's like he
couldn't even he did all that [__] up
[__]
and then ended up dying anyway should
have just killed himself on Discovery
saved all them people well see that's
that's what I always say like right it's
it's just kind of like all those people
that it's you know all you know just
Mass Shooters and all that other kind of
[__] it's like oh I'm gonna take all
these people and you know you know what
just start with yourself okay just do
the world a favor yeah kill yourself you
know what I mean it's like you don't
need to take a bunch of innocent people
with you it's not gonna solve anything
it's not gonna help you he didn't get
away with it you know it's Jesus and
then now I'm wondering if that they
hadn't happened to find Terry Jo which
like I said is kind of like miraculous
that they even found her at all he still
would have been suspect I think they
probably would have still suspected him
I don't know if they would have been
able to prove it because I think the
reason that they I mean I mean they they
thought he was us like to start with
because his story sounded kind of like I
don't know but I but there wasn't any
proof right they never found the boat
they never found the bodies they never
found anything it's difficult to think
about people think that the boats sink
no they're made in ways where they
they'll take on a bunch of water
especially diesel
boats that they're talking about a lot
of times they're filled up with foam
they're semi Unsinkable
unless this is something from an earlier
age
they just take on a lot of water and
they'll be just kind of semi-boyant
I mean they might go down eventually but
like I guess they do eventually go down
but it takes a long time
usually you have time to [__] get a
hold of something things start floating
up out of the boat
as far as I know they have never found
this boat yeah the Blue Bell and they've
never found the body it's like the other
five days it's at the bottom
yeah out in the [__] Bahamas they
took on enough water yeah because they
left from Florida like from Fort
Lauderdale
some of that new [__] they have is it's
near impossible to sink it
well yeah I mean we got good [__]
nowadays this was like back in the 60s
though right so I don't really know
but yeah because like like I said even
the Lifeboat that she was on was like
starting to disintegrate because he had
been out there for so long
creature said uh hey what about the USS
Indianapolis sinking yeah and the Sharks
I can't imagine that experience of just
drifting in the sea here and guys
dragged under by sharks for days and
nights yeah I mean that and the Navy
knowing about it not saying anything I
didn't want to give up just let them get
eaten
I can't imagine like those are my two
yeah worst fears yeah you know what I
mean
it's just kind of like they couldn't put
an SOS out
the Japanese would have intercepted it
probably and they would have known
something was up they were transporting
that atomic bomb
yeah yeah that's what he said he's
carrying parts of what become the atomic
yeah so they had to let the sharks eat
them for a while
they eventually they eventually rescued
him but I don't think the Navy rescued
them did it did they I can't remember
that's a [__] up story too I think
somebody else I think a plane a random
Navy plane saw had reported him in the
water I don't think that was part of the
plan
I don't know I'd have to go back and
look
yeah because uh that definitely seems
like something you'd report if you saw
it yeah I think that I think originally
the Navy was going to let them all just
sit out there and get eaten
it was the sinking of it no no it'll no
it was top secret you know they wanted
they made they made the sinking of the
ship top secret
they didn't want the Japanese to know
or anybody know about it but I think a
plane went overhead
and you're like what what the [__] is
that you know and then they landed and
started helping people and calling for
help I think that's what how it happened
it was a seaplane if I remember
correctly
Larry and creature said the Bluebell is
a chain of pubs in England where I'm
from yeah because that was the name of
the boat Bluebell is uh it's ice cream
it's a brand of ice cream
fantastic Southern ice cream
well wait is it Blue Bell or blue bunny
there's there's two of them there's two
of them there's one called Blue Bunny
also yeah Bluebell is the best one it's
like eating frozen custard it stretches
it's got so many so much eggs in it yeah
it's [__] great
and you can get it in little little
bitty places in Mississippi and they you
know what I mean for like a dollar fifty
for a little pint of it and beautiful
flavors man
Nana pudding Rocky Road
[__] banana split just
uh I can
what's the one uh
pralines and cream
they didn't they didn't they even had
sherbet but they didn't have any there
were no bad flavors
and it was just a
plain looking yellow
carton
with a blue blue trim on it yellow and
blue man [__] was good didn't have any
graphics or anything looked like
something from the 50s
tasted like something it's pretty
minimal yeah
it's the best ice cream I've had in the
United States
to this day second of that would be
Publix ice cream real good yeah their
store brand as well yeah real good
Victor says Bluebell is out of Brenham
Texas is it yeah I know it's Southern
it's all over the hill in the South
that's the South size cream you can get
little dime stores and [__]
it delivered every day
come in here and fill up them damn
coolers because people buy them so
quickly so buy them so fast little gas
stations and stuff that [__] was [__]
great man my dad be visiting my daddy
goes but then go get us some ice cream
yeah he had to drive two miles to go get
some ice cream and [__]
Hugo said uh I survived an earthquake
for myself when I was 16 years old
almost got uh buried under an eighth
story building then I volunteered to
pull people out of the debris but
stopped after four weeks too many dead
people that's [__] up man that reminds
me I forgot to tell you on my way home
from work today about 10 miles from here
I see all these [__] ambulances and
fire trucks and [__] like that screaming
down the road and there's a big old Farm
or something like that just burning it's
burning down they're burning down all
the food manufacturing facilities I mean
it was just I think it was just a house
like with a farm behind it okay but I
was like because I'd been driving and I
was like wow it smells like smoke out
here somebody must be burning some trash
or something I was like oh well that
explains the smell and it was just kind
of like [__] there's fire trucks and
[__] like that everywhere man that [__]
was
burning yep
Jesus Christ so what's the next story
all right the next story uh is the one
that um how long I've been streaming
41 minutes is it time for commercials no
okay it's only 41 minutes after this
we'll do commercials okay yeah
Celtic Angel 73 and said we have blue
bunny here in Wisconsin but I don't
think we have Bluebell yeah we have blue
bunny Too Blue Bunny is also good I've
never had that one but yeah I mean all
ice cream is pretty good to be honest
it's like even even bad ice cream is
still pretty good you know what I'm
saying
but yeah so uh this is the one like I
said this woman that fell out of a plane
now there's two stories and I'm sure
it's happened more than once but the
other one that one you were thinking
about like the the woman that worked on
the plane that was um what was her name
vizna
Bolshevik bilchub something like that
but yeah that was uh just the one where
she was working on the plane and like
she got sucked up she got sucked out
yeah
so this woman this happened in 1971.
and her name is Julianne kepke I think
that's how you pronounce her last name
so uh she was actually she didn't work
on the plane she was just on the flight
and it was a Lancer Flight 508 and this
was on Christmas Eve of 1971. at the
time Julianne kepke was
17 years old
now her and her mom were actually going
from Lima Peru
to the city of pukalpa pukalpa to visit
her dad now her both of her parents were
zoologists I think and they worked in
the Amazon rainforest like they had a um
like a like a thing there so she was um
going to uh follow in their footsteps
she was like really into it so she knew
a little bit about the rainforested
about because you know her parents had a
like a sanctuary thing there
so um she was so should so they're going
out to to visit the dad now they were
supposed to go a couple days earlier but
it's like oh she had a high school
graduation stuff and all this other kind
of thing so mom's like that's okay we
can go on Christmas Eve and we'll go see
him
so she gets on the plane she's in seat
19 f
the plane uh has 86 passengers on it as
well as some crew members as well
now the flight was only supposed to be
an hour long
however 25 minutes into the flight they
hit a huge huge thunderstorm
so the plane basically flies into this
really dense cloud cover and there's
just like lightning flashing all over
the place
now obviously there's a lot of
turbulence inside the cabin like all of
the um you know baggage is like popping
out of the overhead compartments and all
that other kind of stuff and um you know
Julianne's Mom is starting to freak out
a little bit as you would
and then lightning struck the motor
and the plane
basically disintegrated like it just
fell into a bunch of pieces
Julianne uh the quote that she gave said
the next thing I knew I was no longer
inside the cabin I was outside in the
open air I hadn't left the plane the
plane had left me
which is [__] horrifying playing the
plane disintegrated it just broke into
pieces and she was just like falling as
ugh ugh like that's like that and
getting sucked under by sharks is like
my worst [__] fears it makes me never
want to leave the [__] house ever
again
she was still uh strapped into her seat
obviously so she's basically just like
falling in the seat out of the sky so
yeah
uh mercifully she lost Consciousness
which probably like I said very small
Mercy
when she woke up she discovered that she
had fallen 10 000 feet out of the sky
into the middle of the rainforest in
Peru
and she only had quite minor injuries I
mean she did have a broken collarbone
and like some other stuff but nothing
really really bad
so uh and one of her eyes I think was
like swollen shut so she couldn't see
all that good and she like she had a cut
like on her leg
so At first she just kind of like woke
up and sort of realized what happened
and she's like what the [__] and then
like kind of lost Consciousness again
now by the time she kind of woke up and
got her bearings
um it took her several hours to kind of
get to her feet she's kind of hurt and
she's in shock and everything like that
now the first thing she tried to do was
find her mom because like I said she'd
been sitting next to her mom on the
plane but she could not find her
now while she was kind of out exploring
looking for her mom she came across like
a little well or like a little stream or
something like that
so because she had kind of grown up
around the Amazonian rainforest like I
said both her parents were um were
zoologists and you know lived out in the
rainforest like studying the wildlife
and stuff like that so she knew that
it's like oh well all you have to do is
follow water and you'll eventually find
civilization so that's what she decided
to do
so she starts going Downstream and she
walked when she could sometimes she'd
get in the water and swim but she had to
be like kind of careful like you know
piranhas and caimans and things like
that you know not to get eaten
um also she had uh like a wound in her
arm that had like maggots or something
in it like or um you know that were like
kind of eating her so she was kind of
like trying to get rid of that
so uh she was out there
well she was out there for days and days
with no food she did have water because
there was you know a stream and
everything so she could drink out of
that and she would like lick off the
water off the leaves and stuff because
it's rainforest
on the fourth day of her walking around
she came I can't imagine I just can't
imagine
she came across three other passengers
from the plane
they were still strapped into their
seats yeah it was a lot and they had hit
the ground head first and they had hit
so hard that they were buried like two
or three feet down in the dirt and like
their feet were like sticky yeah like
that can you [__] imagine I can't
imagine and one of them two of them were
men and one of them was a woman and she
was like I wonder if that's my mom
and she went over there and took the
shoe off of the woman's corpse because
her mom like and she knew that it wasn't
her mom because her the lady had um nail
polish like on her toes yeah and she's
like and her mom didn't wear a toenail
polish so she's like she knew that
wasn't her but it's like can you imagine
she remember hitting the ground or the
trees
no she doesn't remember no she lost
Consciousness while she was falling as
far as she remembered she's remembered
she woke up on the ground yeah yeah I
wonder how she lit she must have fallen
through the trees yeah I mean it's a
rainforest and there's like a lot of you
know canopy so I'm imagining because
yeah yeah but yeah I think she lost
Consciousness when she was falling like
she said she was aware that she was
falling but then she lost Consciousness
and when she woke up again she was on
the ground
that's it people that's that's what Blue
Bell looks like
look at that yeah
I can't get a good image on there that's
it
that's just [__] good they got a
store locator I'm gonna locate see if we
got a store around here because I
haven't I haven't had that in a while
I think we have it here
Publix has it don't they yeah yeah okay
okay I'm gonna get some
okay
I'm gonna get some that [__]
Larry and creature said yeah if we're
talking [__] up things my neighbor
killed himself last year and just two
days ago my friend who lives about a
mile away from me his neighbor killed
himself by stabbing himself holy [__]
Celtic Angel 73 I fly a few times a year
and it isn't my favorite thing yeah I'm
just I I told you before it's like I I
didn't mind flying the first few times I
did it but then I had like a really
really terrible flight that was very
very stressful and after that I just
dreaded it every single time I love
flying
um Zach says did y'all hear Raquel Welch
died yeah I did hear that actually I
don't think we announced it on the show
but yeah she did is that is that it on
that case no it isn't okay Larry and
creature said I've never been on a damn
plane just Europe and home England fairy
across yeah it's not um it's not fun
mango said right that's put me off
flying not that it would take much
anyway yeah it's like I know
like I said intellectually I know it's
like very very rare that things like
that happen but it's like it still could
happen I mean you might just be that
your number might come up that day and
it's like there's that's really just not
the way I want to go I like helicopters
I like helicopters it's a lot it's a lot
Wilder better
flying with the doors open and stuff
going over nap of the earth just over
Treetop that night man
machine gunner hanging out the side
Huey's uh-60s ch-47s
[__] didn't didn't do didn't do any
little birds but did the other stuff
yeah [__] loved it
Larry and creature said they say it's
better to be limp though and knocked out
like how drunk drivers survive accidents
yeah I think maybe that might have
helped but yeah they always tell you
this too because I remember them telling
this is this in driver's ed for Christ's
sake is that they well they're like yeah
your first instinct usually if something
bad is going to happen is like to tense
up but they're like that is absolutely
not what you should do you should kind
of like you should just go completely
limp yep you hit like a sack of [__] you
are
but that's but maybe that's what I mean
that that probably helped her I think
she went through that she was
unconscious well yeah that probably like
broke her fall too and she had forward
momentum because she was coming out of
it out of an air an aircraft it might
have been doing 400 knots 500 knots so
she must have hit the canopy and she
wasn't in the seat so she didn't have
that much mass you know well she was in
the seat she was in the seat yeah okay
then that means the bottom of the seat
must have hit the branch
and that absorbed a lot of shock
and it slowed her down a lot and then it
started to Tumble after that through the
through the canopy and it landed it the
right way maybe on its back
where it
and it's soft ground and it absorbed the
the final impact
but it must have hit the tree canopy
the right way from from the back you
know I mean it hit a big branch and
probably snapped it and that would have
taken that could that might have sapped
100 miles an hour off of that impact
just that right there you know yeah
it's something like that to have
probably I mean I mean I've come off
motorcycles before probably going about
70.
and you don't have far to fall but that
forward momentum you know it's all kind
of happening at once it's just depends
on the angle of everything you know
whether the road is turning and you it
happens in a turn and you slide off the
road there's a bunch of ways to slow
down you know it's something slowed her
down
going through that canopy yeah because I
mean you know it's the only way 10 000
feet is a long way yeah but terminal
velocity is only about what 130 miles an
hour
but she had forward momentum also
so
there's no telling how much speed she
bled off before she hit the canopy
because she's not falling straight down
you know
so I don't know what her air speed would
have been and what the angle
angle uh in relation to the ground
that's going to be another Factor like I
think that one that one girl who got
sucked out part of the reason why she
survived is she hit around the crest of
a hill
and she went down the back side of the
hill of the slope you know what I mean
her her downward trajectory kind of
lined up with the back end of a slope
and that and she tumbled down it slid
down it that that took most of the speed
off of her
well the one that I was uh the the case
that I was going to talk about before
like of the woman that got sucked out of
the plane and fell like 10 000 feet or
whatever they said she might have
survived because for some of the journey
she was still like sort of in the plane
because she was pinned by a food cart
like in the back yeah of the fuselage so
when it kind of became detached because
her plan also fell apart like in the sky
which
great I just love saying that out loud
well it's because it's spinning it's
ruining itself but yeah so she wasn't
like she was thrown out later but it was
kind of like she had like part of the
plane with her like on the way down but
it was lots of different things it might
have been kind of flat and as it's
spinning it's acting like a parachute
and slowing her down but like I said
terminal velocity I think is 130 miles
an hour equivalent to that
so you're at least gonna hit at 130.
you know
unless there's something unless it's
flat enough to slow you down less than
that
and that's not counting whatever the
forward momentum whatever the forward
velocity of that aircraft was it might
be [__] 600 knots there's no way of
knowing you know it's fast
so it's nothing compared to that 130
miles an hour you got to bleed off all
that speed somehow
Winterfell forever said so Rambo's fall
in First Blood Could Happen imagine that
I don't remember which one that was
I don't remember that Folly fell out of
the out of the helicopter is that what
he's talking about I guess so yeah I
don't remember exactly it's been a while
since I've seen that movie Larry and
creature said cars are way more likely
to kill us but it doesn't take a
psychologist to know why people are
afraid of flying yeah I mean when you're
in a car
um you at least have the illusion of
control because you're steering the [__]
you know what I mean like yeah you could
mess up and kill but I for me like I the
reason I don't like flying is because I
don't like heights
you know what I mean I'm not yeah I'm
bothered by the fact that like yeah I
could get in a car crash it's like I
don't want that to happen but I don't
like the idea of falling out of the sky
of like of being aware that you're
falling all that way that's what I
that's what scares me more than hitting
the ground
I don't like heights either but I don't
get a sensation of heights inside a
helicopter or a an aircraft an airplane
fixed-wing airplane I totally do I don't
get that sensation everything just looks
far away you look down everything looks
far away and then a chopper comes down
to lands it's just it's just nice it
doesn't it doesn't bother me I've jumped
out of helicopters I was on a line 200
foot line
Chopper repel stuff
and that's not too bad for some but I
have a hard time looking down
the side of skyscraper or a photograph
of somebody doing that it's a good it
can upset you know get that vertigo
feeling yeah but I never had that with
aircraft for some reason to me it's all
the same it seems the same to me it
doesn't seem the same to me Celtic Angel
73 thank you very much for the Super
Chat where can I contact you to get your
mailing address I would love to send a
little gift package to your fair warning
I'm a huge procrastinator so it might
take a while
oh thank you you don't have to do that
but that's very very I would appreciate
it
um you can message me on Facebook
or Instagram I mean Facebook is probably
like more likely for me to get it
because sometimes I forget like to check
my messages on Instagram usually I get
them on both like because usually I get
the Instagram ones on Facebook as well
but not always because that's just how
it works out but usually like Facebook
either the 13 o'clock page or something
like that I'll probably get it and I can
send you my uh address if you would like
that mango said just watch out for a
plane crashing onto your car though I've
had a lot of nightmares where it's weird
because I'm really afraid of like being
in a plane crash but I've never had a
nightmare where I was in a plane crash
however I have had several nightmares
where I was on the ground and saw a
plane crash in front of me and I'm not
really sure like why
that if maybe it's my brain like trying
to spare me like the horror I guess it's
like you can watch it from afar you
don't want to be like involved in this
[__] you know what I'm saying yeah but
most of them don't crash the way
described in this where they just
disintegrate in midair that's very rare
most of them most of them crash during
Landing or takeoff
so they're not very high off the ground
anyway
and it's usually some kind of
catastrophic failure or something
and if you watch how it goes it's
it's not really falling it's losing
altitude
you know what I mean so it's it's not
like a dead fall it's flying and the
angle's wrong and then it just it can't
save itself and the wing hits the ground
and it starts to fold up on itself and
it just
gone in a [__] ball of fire those
people never know anything about falling
or anything they're just vaporized it's
[__] hot when that [__] [__] goes
up usually it's full of fuel just
yeah you [__] up you know
Celtic angel said I'm terrified of
heights yet I love roller coasters yeah
I like roller coasters too but the thing
about it is like I'm probably more
scared
um because you know how some roller
coasters or some rides and stuff and you
have to go up the um like the stairs and
stuff like up to the platform that's
scarier to me than the actual roller
coaster is like going up to the high
place like to get there once I'm on the
roller coaster I'm fine I know that
though it's all that anticipation going
click click click click click click no
I'm talking about walking in line I'm
not talking about yeah walking in line
they're talking about when you go to
that version no no no no no no no no I
said once I get on the thing I'm all
right I'm talking about being in line
like walking up the height to the thing
that's what I started walking up that's
what I thought you're talking about no
no no I'm not walking that's like that's
clicking up yeah
Victor says my biggest fear when flying
to Europe and back was someone's
Electronics Catching Fire in the cargo
area while over the Atlantic yeah that's
what I I didn't really like having to
fly across the Atlantic Ocean you know
what I mean it's uh
because there's not a lot of places to
go if something goes wrong and you're
over the ocean for like seven eight nine
hours and I'm just like yeah I didn't
like it I didn't like it you know what I
mean they try to stay over land as long
as possible because they're traffic
going because they fight well I know
that but it's like they you know they
kind of fly like up and over like over
Greenland and [__] like that but they're
still over open ocean like longer than I
would like you know yeah and like I said
bad enough like the [__] plane crash
and then with my luck I'd survive the
crash and then I'd like there'd be
sharks like [__] circling they have
huge um automatically dispensed [__]
um rafts yeah those things that come out
that yeah in the plane I think float for
a long time if they yeah they make
everything like that now yes but it's
like you know that doesn't mean that I
want that I want to go through that your
chances are good on those things
I don't know I I just I don't like the
thought of it I just don't just gotta
man up
man up on that [__] why I don't have to
go anyplace I love this aircraft you
know
uh but yeah I feel like but seriously
[__] the ocean
kind of I don't need to be going out of
the ocean but uh so yeah
so where was I okay so she checked if
one of the one of the dead people was
her mom but it wasn't
um but while she was checking she
actually managed to find a bag of candy
that was the only food that she had like
the whole time she was she had water
like I said because she was in the
rainforest and there was like rain all
over the leaves and everything but she
didn't have any food but she did have
she did find a little bag of candy so
that's just what she ate like the rest
of the time
um now because the plane had crashed
there was obviously a rescue mission but
they didn't really know where the plane
was because you know it's the rain
forest so it's super super thick and
they couldn't really see anything
from the air
so you know she kept she kept seeing and
hearing like planes and helicopters and
[__] like that like going over and was
trying to like get their attention but
they never saw her because the canopy
was too thick
so basically
um she had been she was in the forest
for nine days
and she finally found a Hut but there
was nobody in it so she's like well I'm
gonna go in here and sleep and maybe
like somebody lives here and they'll
come back
and then she's like well but if nobody
comes back there's nothing else around
so I'm probably just gonna die out here
because I don't honey food or anything
so she was out there resting in this
place and then she hears voices
and then she sees three guys it's three
loggers and they were the ones who lived
in the Hut and they came out and they're
like what the [__] like who's this
person and she was like oh my God I'm
saved and she's like she said the first
guy looked like an angel the men though
were like afraid of her they thought
that she was
um a water spirit
that's what they said they well they
didn't know I guess she looked kind of
[__] up and she was kind of wounded
and everything so I don't know like she
was a ghost why they thought that yeah
they thought she was like some kind of
Supernatural whatever so they were like
okay well she's like no seriously I was
just in a plane crash it's fine
um so they actually let her stay there
overnight and then the next day they had
to like put her in a boat and it was
like a long way like to the hospital
so she had been in the jungle for 11
days she had water but only a bag of
candy and she was kind of she wasn't
horribly wounded but she was kind of
what she did have a broken collarbone
she had like a um a big gash in her leg
I think she had a cut in her arm that
had like maggots and [__] in it because
I think at the hut she actually found a
thing of gasoline and was like pouring
though
because they were like eating her flesh
or whatever but here's here's the thing
though if that ever happens to you in
this situation leave them maggots in
there
all right it sounds crazy
but they're eating
[__] dead flesh and infected flesh
there's actually some hospitals that'll
put those things in there they're grown
in a sterile environment they'll put
them in there and they'll strip off any
kind of dead flesh anything that's
infected they can't they don't have any
teeth so they can't eat anything that's
any living material off of you so it
ends up being pretty Surgical
just let them eat it
keep the inspection the infection from
spreading or if it does spread it's
they're getting it as it goes it's not
going to get that bad you know
yes I wouldn't recommend [__]
cleaning them out but I imagine it's
probably [__] gross seeing them in
there well yeah it has been days and
days and it was just probably like I
want maybe if they may have saved her
though
those [__] maybe have saved her from
[__] that could happen yeah
yeah it'll always look on the bright
side yeah it's like yeah I got a weird
full of maggots but
they can only eat dead flesh they can't
eat living flesh
that you know of unless you got well
unless you got one that goes Rogue they
use them they use them to [__] get
rid of like yeah yeah I've heard of that
yeah
mango said that would have been a bad
ending found and burnt to the stake for
being mistaken for a water witch I know
wouldn't that have been a [__] like
that but she survived all the survived a
plane crashed survived like 11 days in
the jungle and then like she got killed
by yeah somebody thinking she was like a
[__] supernatural being or something
so uh so yeah so she was uh eventually
rescued
and uh she helped the authorities go and
find the wreckage
and they did uh recover all of the
bodies eventually and she actually had
to help identify some of them uh there
had been 92 people on board like I said
86 of them were passengers including her
she was the only one that survived
um she did find out later on uh I guess
they were able to determine this is kind
of shitty but her mom because remember
she was on the play with her mom they
were able to determine that her mom had
also survived the crash but
um had succumbed to her injuries after
right like being like being in the
garage she just she didn't know where
she was she was looking for her like
Julianne was looking for but she
couldn't find her but they said that the
mom had probably lived a day or two also
what was the injuries did they say um I
don't know but they but they were like
really really bad they said that yeah
they said that a couple of the other
passengers had actually survived the
crash like they were still alive when
they hit the ground but they died later
on because their injuries were too bad
and they hadn't been found so some of
them they think that they did live a
couple of days Julian was just like
super super lucky that she fell in a
particular and she wasn't horribly
horribly injured and was still able to
walk and like go and find help and stuff
um so yeah she uh not surprisingly
developed a really um intense fear of
flying after this which you know can't
blame her for that uh and had really bad
PTSD like recurring nightmares and stuff
um but you know she was able to kind of
get her [__] together she you know did
just like um she was going to she got
reunited with her dad you know her mom
died obviously but
um she went and studied biology and
became a you know zoologist just like
she had wanted to just like her parents
and she went back to uh Peru and studied
mammals and then got married later on
now uh verder Herzog actually made a
documentary about her called Wings of
Hope in 1998 and he took her back to the
Peruvian jungle like where the plane
crash was and he filmed her like walking
around the area which you'd think would
be kind of [__] up but it had been
like several years and she um she said
it was actually really therapeutic like
going back to the spot again and like
retracing her steps like where she had
been
um so
they said that when when she was flying
to Peru with Burner Herzog she said
she's she had the same seat number 19f
as she had in the plane I'd have been
like no I'm getting off this plane right
now it's [__] cursed but yeah uh she
also wrote a book about her experiences
and it's called when I fell from the sky
which is
yikes I can't [__] imagine I mean
this is horrible
what it's time for commercials is it yes
it is are you sure yes it is go ahead
and do the commercials and take a break
Thomas and Tom's making me do
commercials we have to do that no this
is a business I'm just kidding
um and then we have one more case to
talk about which is
really [__] up welcome to again really
[__] up all right so we're gonna do
some commercials and then we'll come
back and talk about one more [__] up
case so we'll be back in just a minute
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
all right we're back
what's your fellow forever said I had
maggots that a uh especially vicious
Brazilian fly leaves you in form of eggs
under your skin
yeah I think I saw
um remember that show that used to be on
was it Monsters Inside Me that damn
kuritaba or whatever that like lays
attitude
yikes that [__] is so gross
is that show still on that was like that
was a good show
like it's about being infested with some
comparison with various things
parasites and bugs did you like that it
was horrifying to watch but it was still
like kind of fascinating at the same
time
um all right so the next case that I
want to talk about last case I want to
talk about this is another one that uh
Celtic Angel recommended and this is
again another case that I hadn't heard
of even though it's technically like a
true crime case so I don't know why I
didn't hear about this one but this
happened in 1978.
and this is the case of Mary Vincent
so in 1978 Mary Vincent was 15 years old
and she was in Berkeley California where
she lived
now her big thing was she wanted to be a
dancer and she was apparently like very
very good at it so I guess that was her
big dream or whatever
so she was also I feel like
um a little bit troubled I don't know if
I'd say troubled but maybe like
rebellious which I guess a lot of
teenagers are around that age when she
was 15.
um her parents were getting divorced and
she decided she was going to run away
from home I don't know if this was the
first time that she had done this but
she decided that she was going to
hitchhike to Los Angeles now it's the
70s nobody hitchhikes well people do
hitchhike nowadays but I think it's only
when they're desperate like normally you
would not hitchhike but I kind of feel
like in the late 60s and early 70s you
know the late 70s it was just a thing
like people did it all the time and I
don't think they really thought all that
much about it
even though
man I've written about so many cases
where
somebody was hitchhiking and they got
murdered so which is almost what
happened here
but yeah
so she decides she's going to hitchhike
to Los Angeles
so
she's out there for a little while
and then a Blue Van
stops
now the guy behind the wheel didn't look
terribly uh threatening uh you know he
was middle-aged kind of guy she said
kind of reminded her of her grandfather
now I've heard some other versions of
the story that it's like she was kind of
like there were some other people around
her like also hitchhiking
and I think some of the older girls that
were hitchhiking kind of like said to
Mary Vincent it's like hey don't go with
that guy like he seems super sketch but
she didn't think that he seemed all that
sketchy like I said he seemed kind of
like grandfatherly
so she didn't really initially have any
reason to fear him so she gets into the
car
now this guy as it turns out she didn't
know this until later
but um he was actually a uh Merchant
Marine Seaman and his name was Lawrence
Singleton
now she wanted to go to uh Interstate
five and he said yeah I'll drive you
just you know hop on it
now apparently they drove for some time
um you know just and everything was
normal is that he seemed completely
normal
she was even felt so safe that she even
took a nap at some at one point and like
woke up and everything was fine
however a few hours into the journey
she fell asleep again and then woke up
and realized that he was not heading
toward where he said he was going to be
heading she fell asleep he's like oh
[__] she's sleeping I'm taking her
somewhere yeah that's pretty much what
happened
so uh she immediately gets really
suspicious and I guess there was like a
like a pointed stick like a surveyor
stick like in the car so she grabbed it
and like kind of pointed it at him and
it's like hey take me back to where you
said you were going to your
[__] stab you which you know
that's what you would do
um and he's like oh and as you know
never I just I just made a wrong turn or
something like that it's fine it's fine
yeah that's a likely story
so um so yeah so he turns back around
he's like see look I'm going back to the
interstate I just it was an honest
mistake that's nothing to get alarmed
about
so then he drives like a few more miles
and then he's um he's like well I gotta
take a leak so he pulls the car over to
the side of the road
um and I can't you know wait till we get
to the rest stop or whatever
so Mary decides okay well while he's
doing that she's going to get out and
kind of stretch her legs or whatever so
she gets out of the car and then she
notices one of her uh shoelaces is
untied so she bends over to tie it
and while she was doing that this
[__] snuck up behind her and hit
her in the side of the head with a
sledgehammer damn and knocked her
unconscious she didn't see the
sledgehammer no I guess he just like
well she was just like going down like
that and he just like came up like snug
up behind her yeah and hit her that with
a hand how old is this guy
she's like middle-aged oh she said
grandfatherly so I was thinking [__]
yeah but she's only 15. okay so you know
he's probably 40. yeah that's what I
mean yeah
so yeah so she's unconscious
so while she's unconscious
again this [__]
takes her out to this [__] remote
area
rapes her
sodomizes her
several times
and then she keeps going in and out of
Consciousness and then after a while she
starts like begging him to like let her
free
at which point he throws her down on the
ground she's losing Consciousness
because of the head injury
Yeah well yeah because we're heading
because of like the trauma and
everything
so he throws her on the ground
takes out a hatchet
and cuts off her arms damn both of them
damn
just hacking yeah
away at her arms damn while she is just
like shrieking it's great and she said
this is so [__] up I I because I
watched like a thing about uh with her
like later on
um she said that she was like um I guess
she was kind of like trying to grab him
like that
and she had her hands like that and he
chopped and she fell backward and then
she realized one of her arms is still
grabbing on him grabbing onto his shirt
and I was like oh my God can you [__]
imagine like her arm was still that's a
sharp ass hatchet
yeah I wonder where he got that hatchet
I don't know he sharpened it in in
preparation for this usually a hatch
it's not real good at cutting through
stuff like that geez it's for wood you
know what I mean they're not they're
kind of dull they cut her [__] arms
off man
so he cuts it he cuts one off and then
the other arm yeah like while she's
laying there yeah damn
and then was he saying anything
well wait okay yeah
see so we cut well you just keep trying
you keep trying to jump ahead like when
I'm not done with this stuff
[Laughter]
so not only does he cut both of her arms
off like at the forearms look at the
elbow
then he picks her up
and throws her off like a cliff type
thing it's like 30 feet or something
like that throws our thing then he goes
down there and stuffs her in a culvert
and it's like there now you're free he
said because she said you know hey can
you let me free or something all right
he knew she was alive huh
well he didn't think she was gonna
[__] I don't I don't know if he knew
she was alive at that point like because
after he threw her over the thing
yeah yeah
so
just for the record
this 15 year old girl has been raped and
sodomized multiple times
has had both of her arms cut off has
been thrown off a cliff and then stuffed
into a culvert
head first
I guess yeah yeah like a pipe okay yeah
Jesus Christ
so then this [__] dude just gets in
his car and like drives off like it's
totally [__] normal like it's the
most normal thing to do
now the next morning
um Mary Vincent gets found by two women
how the hell they find her listen to
this yeah
she actually managed to get out of the
Culvert yeah and get back up on the road
the two women were driving by and they
saw her walking along the road naked
with no arms and her arms she was
holding them up like that she said later
she was trying to keep the blood and the
muscles from falling out damn that's
what she said in the court doctor they
never found arms huh no damn
but he said can you imagine like driving
down the street and seeing like a naked
girl like little girl like driving with
her arm with no arms like holding her
arms up like that
I heard I don't know if this is true or
not but I heard that like a guy like
kind of slowed down but was like [__]
this action and like kept going freaked
him out too bad was freaking him out
which I guess it would but that's still
that's not excusable I mean you really
should you need to help that person so
um he couldn't believe it yeah and then
he's like man they'll blame me or some
[__] like that you know yeah maybe
that's what she died still playing me
she'll they'll blame me
something like that but yeah in the US
they probably would
well yeah because in the car where
they've been [__] she died in the car
they'd probably would [__] blame him
well because 99 of the time that's who
[__] did it yeah you know I hate to
say but that's just statistically told
me he might have been did it in a weird
way did the self-preservation route
maybe but the thing is you could chop
out and put you could jump out and put
tourniquets on her so she didn't lose
any more blood yeah and if she wasn't
dead by then she's not gonna die
she had been down well she did it yeah
she was down there overnight yeah I have
a heart with no arms yeah I have a hard
time understanding how you can cut
through such a large artery
without any kind of tourniquet on there
and not lose all your blood I mean that
must be she must add some badass
coagulation [__] abilities I guess
I mean I can't imagine well like I said
that's why you lose a limb it kills you
if you yeah if you don't apply pressure
to it you know
I mean maybe she did I don't know like
you know I don't know how could she
apply pressure to right that's what I
mean she was probably unconscious dad in
that pipe for a while
yeah and gestures for me said how did
she not go into shock so that's that's
I'm sure she did she probably wasn't
shocked
I mean she had to have oh yeah
she probably didn't feel a thing
I hope not you could dissociate
disassociated from your body yeah
because your brain usually has like a
little mechanism where it's like
checking out yeah we don't want we don't
want to have you to deal with this yeah
um
I mean think about it most mammals
animals are gonna have that ability I
guess just given to you by Nature
somehow
most animals in nature die from being
eaten alive you know that's a [__]
bad way to go
I mean these beautiful birds of prey you
know these [__] Eagles and [__]
grabbing the family cats and ripping it
apart while it's alive you know I mean
they're [__] bad way of going
you know but that's how most animals go
so humans probably inherited that from
our animal ancestors where you can just
mentally check out like you're not there
you know like you've seen it from above
type of deal
yeah there's too much sensory overload
too much
too much [__] uh there's no reason to
go through it so you just shut it all
down you know
yeah I mean
he's [__] great well just like you
know those toolbox Killers yeah
according to the recording so what they
were doing the problem was that they
couldn't get the girls to scream loud
enough
they probably weren't feeling a whole
lot through all that adrenaline and [__]
going through them and going into shock
it probably didn't feel much
they say the body down under torch or
shuts down pretty pretty rapidly
well yeah and then I imagine you know
everybody's different but some because
the experience of it is just so surreal
I guess in a lot of ways and like you
said you just kind of go into shock and
you might just associate yeah that's
kind of like a lot of people's way of
dealing with it
that's why those Mongolians were so good
breaking people's Souls over times with
those [__] coffin prisons back in
back in the early 1900s it just put you
in a box that you can't really stood up
or
it's not it's small box you can't but
you can't stretch out it's got a little
hole in the center and they just keep
you in there
I think they let you out once a week
but you're in there with your own [__]
and everything
stacked inside this damn prison it's
like a Mongolian prison they're banned
now you know what I mean there's some
photographs surviving it you know
people's heads trying to look through
that little hole
um
the prison guards if they had mercy on
somebody they just leave them outside
and winter and let them starve and not
give them a blanket for that night and
they'd [__] freeze to death
it's usually how they kind of Mercy
killed them
but some of them weren't there for years
and come out came out but you did oh
[__] man you'd be [__] up it'd take
another couple years three years to
mentally get right after living in that
box
yeah I'm sure some people will probably
never recover yeah like I said you can't
really blame them most of them died in
there
you know I mean most of them never
completed their sentences
some of them had it for life in there
too
Tammy said maybe when he threw her into
the pipe somehow she landed on her arms
just right to apply some pressure yeah
maybe maybe they were kind of like
pressed down against the Congress how'd
she get out though
yeah I guess so
Larry and creature said uh one time my
granddad said he saw someone get crushed
working construction like his chest
caved in and for a few seconds after it
happened the guy said it's okay I'm fine
then he died instantly yeah yeah you say
[__] like that yeah
um
dentosama is that how you pronounce that
hey I'll be listening during work but
how are you two we're good how are you
doing yeah talking about some [__]
crazy survival stories in infantry you
know you hear all kinds of tales about
dudes that got shot and
a lot of them just ripped their shreds
instantly and just killed you know
at close range
but every now and then you hear one
where a guy gets [__] hit by enemy an
enemy round and [__] looks to the guy
next to him and goes he missed but then
but he didn't miss he he hit him and
then two guys died and he died you know
[__] put a hole right through him
[__] long ways through the through
the Torso
and he was he missed
and then died
so he didn't even know that the bullet
hit him I mean in a way I guess that's
better because you don't suffer yeah but
that's like yeah
that's it's better than just like
sitting there feeling every single some
of them do yeah that's what I mean it's
like it's you and you probably never
know until yeah until it happens to you
like which kind of person you are
you would think that most people would
have like survival thing where your body
would just be like
like if something's that
traumatic you know what I mean
but uh but yeah I've been in fights
fights that are so bad got punched in
the [__] solar plexus and all of a
sudden I was standing behind myself
seeing myself from the back like it
knocked my soul out
yeah and he's seen the fight from
looking down on it and you're losing
yeah
[Laughter]
some of you guys maybe have been in that
no I haven't
uh okay so
yeah see these two women see her walking
down the street like holding her arms up
so her blood wouldn't fall out that's
that's [__] crazy
so they take her to the hospital now
listen this girl is such a badass not
only did she survive all of that
but they got her to the hospital got the
tourniquets on everything like that she
was able to give such a good description
of the [__] that did this to her
that his neighbor recognized him from
the picture and called the cops okay
yeah I know that [__]
I said Singleton dude yeah yeah so she
was not so she was cogent enough to give
like a really good description because
she was with him well yeah I mean well
we're getting we'll get into that he
must have been a serial killer yeah I'm
not sure about that because they only
well okay well I'll get into it like I
said you're jumping ahead but um but
yeah so they call the cops
now
okay so this is kind of [__] up this
is you know the 1970s
now he got
um put on trial and he got convicted
but he only got
14 years
because it was only considered attempted
murder which is dumb because I kind of
feel like he was probably pretty sure
that he that she was dead like and that
was his intention clearly yeah
so I kind of feel like they probably
should have punished him as if she had
died yeah but that's that's being guilty
of murder
he didn't kill her he failed to kill her
so it was attempted yeah it's just that
in this case the maximum sentence of 15
years isn't enough and that's not enough
because of like look what he [__] did
to her that state didn't have there are
some states that have certain
you know what I mean enhancements you
know what I mean where oh you know
because this happened during a rape and
because kidnapping was involved and all
this and that like some states just
kidnapping alone is life
yeah okay so that this also constitutes
kidnapping and kidnapping is just taking
someone somewhere where they do not want
to go right against their will actively
all right uh the state of Louisiana
that's life
that's life sentence and it's usually a
way of getting a rapist locked up for
life because they usually have to kidnap
a person
no so
should have been yeah you got 15 years
for the [__] attempt to murder but it
got life for the kidnapping right and
got 60 years for the [__] all the
sexual assault stuff that he did so
there's all kinds of ways that they
should have got him yeah yeah
Well yeah if you thought 14 years wasn't
enough just for attempted murder yeah
um oh and by the way at the trial like
she was there like giving
um you know giving testimony and
everything like that she's got fake arms
well now she does yeah
um and he
threatened her he basically came and
whispered to her it's like I'm gonna
finish the job like when I get out yeah
no no Jesus Christ so did she charge him
a terroristic threat
see I don't know but terroristic threats
another one that they can get you on but
so he got 10 years right there right
sometimes so he got sentenced to 14
years yeah however
he only served eight years and four
months
because good behavior yeah you got a
good behavior they had to do 50 of his
time so they let him yeah
yeah
even though like a lot of his
psychiatrists and everything like that
said um said don't let that [__] out
um that he constitutes an elevated
threat because of his uh hostility
and he actually so not only did he
threaten Mary Vincent but he also wrote
letters to Mary Vincent's lawyer
threatening them as well damn they
didn't use any of that against him so
yeah it was the 70s everything was just
like whatever
yeah it's fine that damn toxic lead in
the [__] environment nobody was
worried about the [__] hole Criminal
Justice System the judges are like I
gotta be all right it'll hit a problem
if it's not oh well yeah well just
people I mean yeah just Jesus Christ
so um she should have been hitchhiking
alone she shouldn't have been wearing
that dress well that's what I mean
they're gonna victim
I mean they still do that now but it was
like way worse in the 70s yeah well you
shouldn't have been doing this and you
shouldn't have been doing that don't you
know that girls get raped I mean [__]
you didn't know that
I mean I'm not [__] look
I'm not making fun of the of wisdom
you really shouldn't be doing anything
unwise but 15 year old girls are
unfucking wise okay well yeah that's
kind of like the definition of a
teenager you do dumb [__] that's just
what you do
I it just it makes me mad because I
always kind of feel like they're always
like well you shouldn't have been
wearing that or you shouldn't have been
at that party or you she's been drinking
man and I was like but they never really
seemed to tell the the guys well you
shouldn't be raping people yeah duh well
like why is it always like why is the
onus always on the victim to like do
something different I don't think that's
the the I don't think that's what their
intent is of why they're doing that it's
the fact is is they just go man you know
you got hurt
you should have known better because
it's a dangerous place that's that's the
thinking but they're not going to say so
we're gonna let this guy off like he's
supposed to do it that's not what
they're talking about
but the thing is is like yeah that
girl's 15 15 year olds are [__] dumb
even smart ones are dumb they just don't
have the life experience their brains
aren't developed until you're [__]
what 22 23 anyway
and the thing about the 70s was that I
mean this isn't an excuse but a lot of
people hitchhiked yeah and 95 of the
time it was fine yeah that's dumb though
too it is dumb but I'm just saying that
people did it a lot back then and most
of the time it was fine it's just like
that you know a few percentage points
that you know would happen be a serial
killer yeah you know they thought it was
like catching the train I guess but yeah
it's just weird how casual people were
about it back then I wrote about so many
cases where you know teenage girls and
stuff nowadays like Jesus they would
never do that they order Uber and
they're scared to get into the Uber
because they don't like how the Dude
Looks well because some of the some Uber
drivers are rapists too that's happened
yeah so you know you can't trust nobody
that's what I'm saying right and I kind
of feel like even nowadays like when you
have all these you know uh things in
place and everybody knows that yeah but
you still have to be suspicious of it
what's funny is that when you actually
analyze it
the difference in wisdom between a 15
year old and a 10 year old isn't very
much about the same
they're they're they so blaming her
would be like blaming a 10 year old
you know
and that's the thing like I said a lot
of teenagers and I just feel like you
know it'd be different I don't know it's
like even if it'd be different if you
were an adult and you just like oh they
should know better but even then it's
just kind of like that that doesn't mean
that come to think about it though that
doesn't mean that that gives people
right to like do terrible [__] to you
just because you did a stupid thing you
kind of think of it though you know I
had I got these two little Cajun cousins
okay they were cute as [__] it was a
couple years between them
lived there from there from Louisiana
they were a little more they were
probably more together and more reliable
a little more wise at 10 than they were
at 15 probably though those hormones
kick in and they [__] did stupid [__]
but when they were younger they were
more even-headed so
if a 15 year old might be dumber than a
10 year old in a certain in in terms of
making a decision
yeah maybe because they're just not
under the same hormonal forces you know
like oh I gotta go out tonight you know
I mean a 10 year old doesn't think that
way right you know I'm gonna stay home
you know
so it's that kind of [__] yeah you're
getting a lot more trouble
so yeah so not only did this
[__] threaten her the victim
said oh I'm gonna finish the job when I
get out and called and like wrote
letters to her lawyer like threatening
them as well
so he gets out of prison well so like
even when he was still in prison not
surprisingly Mary Vincent was like had
really bad PTSD because she just kept
thinking oh he's gonna get out and he's
gonna come back and get me because
that's what he said right I mean he
knows who she is I'd be [__] scared
too
so
she um had a real hard time uh obviously
uh you know so like I said she wanted to
be a dancer that was her that was all
she ever wanted to do and that was her
dream and she can't do it now she
doesn't have any arms and they also use
some like flesh and stuff like from her
leg like for skin grafts because I've
seen like she it's just she has like
it's just there
and she got prosthetic she got like
hooks
like back then but the thing about it
was that she didn't get any compensation
or anything like that
um so when her prosthetic arms broke
like she couldn't afford to get them
fixed like later on she had to like file
for bankruptcy and [__] like that and
she just had years and years of like
horrible depression
um you know and Nightmares and
everything like that because of what
this stupid [__] did to her and
he was and she just kept being worried
that he was gonna get out and like come
back and kill her you know what I mean
but uh eventually in 1999 uh she you
know met a guy and got married and uh
went on and had a couple of kids and
then finally she was able to kind of
sort of come to like some kind of piece
about it and became like kind of a
victims advocate what happened to the
dude but well that's I'm getting to that
you can just like stop jumping ahead
it's like I don't know [__] man [__] I'd
find that do not smash his ass well
listen to this [__] listen to this [__]
so yeah so she couldn't be a dancer but
it's like she did actually like learn to
draw with her prosthetic so she got like
really good at that
so Lauren Singleton he did his eight
years in four months which is pathetic
and got out
and then he moved to Florida because of
course he did that's where that's where
all the scumbags come to they all move
here it's they call it Florida man for a
reason so uh so yeah this is this is the
one of the worst examples of Florida man
so he moves here
and um Everybody kind of like well they
didn't nobody wanted him in California
like he tried to move they tried to like
put him in all these other neighborhoods
and everybody's like oh no absolutely
not
um and they were like yeah they're like
we don't want we don't want him here
uh so yeah they put like Signs out front
saying like drop dead and all this other
kind of stuff so he moved to Florida
this was in 99. uh no this was like a
little earlier than that I think
and no I guess I guess it was where it
was right around the 90s because he was
jailed in what 1978 1979 something like
that and then like he was in for eight
years in four months yeah it's about 90.
so a couple of years after he got out he
was in Florida
in his house
and there was a house painter who was
working in the neighborhood
it was in Tampa actually
and he was walking by this house and he
happened to like look in the window or
like the sliding glass door or something
like that
and he sees a naked man raising his arm
like up and going up and down like that
and then
underneath was like a woman who was like
slouched over the couch who looked like
she was covered with blood
and the painter said it sounded like
bones crushing like he heard a noise
like bones crushing
so the cops show up
and uh guess who it was in the house
Lawrence Singleton it was his house and
there was blood all over the place
now he tried to come up with some
[__] excuse she she fell or yeah some
[__] like that yeah yeah
um but yeah I wasn't walking I was
walking I had the knife and then she
fell
like six times yeah yeah she just fell
on it I don't know how it happened it
was a freak accident yeah
so um Turned out
that this woman who she was dead uh in
the house
she was a woman named Roxanne Hayes she
was 31. she was a sex worker he had
hired her for twenty dollars
uh you know and she had come over yeah
uh she had three small children at home
that she was trying to support and this
[__] just [__] stabbed her
uh with a boning knife
so they caught him now see now I thought
before like okay were they fighting over
something or he just brought her over to
kill her I don't know actually I mean it
seemed like
I kind of feel like he probably just
wanted to kill her
why are you doing house though
because he's a dumbass yeah I don't know
these aren't the brightest bulbs in the
tree you know what I mean but um
we'll see that's the thing now what he
did to Mary Vincent in 1978 the fact
that he
very calculatedly like picked her up and
then like took her a long way and like
didn't do anything but then like oh by
the way like hit her with a hammer and
then like did all that weird [__] with
like cutting her arms off and everything
I kind of suspect that that wasn't the
first time that he had done that no I
don't know but I don't and then the fact
that he did it again like after he got
out like he you know picked up a woman
like you know a sex worker like he hired
her and then took her to the house and
like just chopped her up and I was just
kind of like I kind of wonder if there's
other
victims out there that they don't know
about oh absolutely because
jumping right to cutting a 15 year old
girl's arms off yeah just that's not a
first timer move no so I kind of feel
like this [__] probably did some
[__] prior to that based on the on the
escalations that usually happen in other
cases that we've covered some dudes
never get to the point where they're
cutting them up like that but the ones
that do cut them up and do that kind of
[__] usually that's at least the third
one fourth one that's what I'm saying
before they start doing that kind of
stuff so now I'm kind of wondering if
Mary Vincent was not his first victim I
doubt there were six or seven probably
it's just they never pin stuff on them
because like I said it was the 70s and
like a lot of people were hitchhiking
and like transient and you know oh my
goodness Pookie's like messing she's not
getting [__] over stop molesting spot
she's like but I love this box
that is [__] mirror Spock man he's in
the Mirror Universe yeah he's not safe
he's dangerous
he's not safe yes but yeah so uh so they
catch this [__] I mean well too
late to save that second woman
unfortunately
um and too late to save Mary Vincent's
arms unfortunately
but um yeah so they caught him and they
like put him on trial and Mary is like
well I'm gonna have to go testify
because I want them to put him away like
for [__] life this time
uh she didn't want to but she kind of
felt obligated
so um so yeah she went and testified at
the trial and sat up there in the stand
and said you know he raped me cut my
arms off you know and he left me to die
um you know and they said that it was
kind of impact I know this is [__] up
but it was like really impactful because
like she pointed at him and like she
just has a hook for it and you know
obviously that's [__] up yeah they got
some stylish new arms now you know the
little that girl who's she lost both her
arms yeah the one that got the got her
arms bitten off by sharks or no shark
she's uh I think she's British I think I
think it was uh she got some kind of
frostbite and lobster I don't think uh
when she was a little kid they gave her
them damn it lead to battle age alarms
and she's got all the different colored
ones and the it went just like I said
remember I said man why do they make
these Prosthetics [__] that nasty
looking fake flesh colored with all that
weird [__] you said make them [__]
gloss black and silver and yeah make
them like badass yeah and that's what
she's they're all like and they've got
pressure pads in there she can move the
fingers they're not directly wired into
her nervous system like I think they'll
eventually be one day but we probably
wouldn't have to do it that way be an
implant the chip implant in your brain
that would probably just wirelessly
communicate yeah that's what I think
they're working on that that's be the
way to do it but um I want ones like
like lizard hours like with scales and
[__] that'd be cool hers look like a
from Elita battle Angel they look like
that they look good I don't want my arms
they look real good yeah
and she take them off put them back on
and does like fashion stuff they got
lights in them
you know batteries and [__] see that's
pretty cool so if you're gonna have fake
arms [__] decorate them yeah might as
well yeah you do like a [__]
knowledge yeah I don't want him to look
realistic that's boring like oh clitus
from [__] Flash Gordon the [__]
gold [__] plated
mechanical Armature yeah
support that [__]
but yeah so it was yeah I don't know if
she has different ones nowadays but like
I said when she was testifying at this
fucker's trial
um you know she just had the the hook
hands yeah
um but yeah so she testified and that
probably went a long way toward getting
him put on death row death [__] row
yeah
um however uh he died in 2001 actually
of cancer hope it was ass cancer and I
hope it was painful yeah
uh you know because Jesus [__] Christ
so yeah I mean
I guarantee you
that was a serial killer and and it had
to have been nobody just decides to do
that one no and it usually doesn't start
at that level usually no
I mean because I don't think like he
necessarily planned or anything like
that but it's like he seemed
it seemed like he was kind of calm and
he had like a like a plan for what to
like you know how I'm gonna get rid of
the body and you know and the fact that
he was just so callous yeah toward her
like that it's like he must have done
that before yeah that was something he
started in his teens and then like I
said the fact that he was in prison for
you know eight and a half years then he
gets out then a couple years later he
does it again yeah
I'm sure that there's other victims
there of that of that guy and how old
was he when he got out
I don't know she said old man right
no she said that he reminded him before
the witness said he saw an old man
stabbing the woman no a naked man I said
it naked okay I was thinking for some
reason I thought of a [__] naked old
man
I wonder how old he was then well that's
on you isn't it why are you thinking
about naked old men that's just what I
imagined because I imagine him being in
his 40s or 50s when he got locked up
anyway so I thought there might have
been like I said I'm not entirely sure
because you know she said oh he reminded
me of my grandpa but like I said he was
she was only 15 so it's like he might
not have been that old right like she
might have just perceived him he was
only locked up for about eight years
yeah so he wasn't that much older really
yeah he might have just like been in his
50s or something like 50s or 60s Maybe
but still it's like
I don't know now I'm kind of like
curious to see if
um
Larry and creature said is there any of
him admitting to further crimes in
prison I don't think that he's not that
I know of anyway I'd have to like look
it up
but Lawrence Singleton was his name they
know that he that he did that
um you know Roxanne Hayes they know that
he killed her because they caught him
right-handed essentially and you know
they know that he attempted to kill Mary
Vincent but other than that I don't know
if there's like other ones but I kind of
feel like there's probably are oh no
because like you said that that MO is
just very serial killery yeah Mr 88 said
he was born in 1927. so he was just shy
of 50 in 1978. okay yeah so he was late
like late 40s yeah yeah so he's still
doing that [__] when he's out there
like an old man yeah like out there
picking up prostitutes and killing them
he was a serial killer yeah he had to
have been yeah that was just like I said
nobody nobody knows just jumps right to
that
that's [__] crazy there was a bunch
of them out there they don't know about
probably other guys got playing for him
other serial killers probably got blamed
for a lot of it who knows
or they just bodies weren't found
depending on where he was living at the
time might have been a place where you
could get rid of bodies I mean I kind of
feel like well you know because I wrote
about
um you know like the Texas Killing
Fields and like all that kind of stuff
which they know was at least three
different serial killers and probably
more
and a lot of them they just don't know
who they are yeah yeah it's just all
these bodies were just dumped in the
same place and it's like they might
still be bodies out there that they
don't know they don't know who the girls
are they don't know who they don't know
who the killers are they don't know who
some of the girls are either like some
of the victims are not identified
they've identified most of them at this
point but um they found so many what was
it like 30 40 bodies out there like in
this one kind of like several acre area
uh you know part of Texas and they know
for a fact because they caught some of
the dudes later on they know for a fact
it was at least three but then some of
the victims the DNA like from those
three doesn't match so it's like there's
more than three now those three sericos
did they know each other
I don't know and it that was never
addressed I don't know well not that I
remember okay so it's not like they were
working together I don't think so well
the thing about it is like a lot of them
were like truckers you know what I mean
because I kind of feel like particularly
back in the 60s and 70s there was a lot
of serial killers like Truckers or had
jobs like that where they were like
traveling from place to place and they
would just like stop and pick up
hitchhikers or runaways or whatever
you know like somebody would like a
teenage girl run away from home
I would be hitchhiking and they would
pick them up and kill them and just dump
them on the side of the road and then
they would just like be on to the next
city and no one would suspect anything
so I kind of feel like there was a lot
of that going on in the 60s and 70s and
probably
I mean they've caught some of them but I
bet there's a lot of them that they
didn't catch too and I bet there's like
a bunch of bodies out there that they've
never found yet either who just dreams
this [__] up you're a trucker you know
what I mean like you know what I'm gonna
kill this [__]
who thinks like that they do I don't
think like that well thank God so you
know what I'm saying doesn't even cross
your mind I mean what would make them
even what makes them even start thinking
like that they must have been thinking
like that before they became truckers it
must have been something yeah when they
were kids it has to be
yeah I mean yeah it's not like
I'm a trucker I'm driving around and
then I'm you slowly like morph into
let's start killing these lot lizards I
don't it just no I think what it is
because I you know remember I was
looking uh up something before and they
were talking about like the um the
professions that are more that are like
more highly represented among serial
killers it's usually like trickers the
truckers forestry workers cops
um you know security guards that type of
stuff and I don't think it's necessarily
oh the people in that job like turn into
serial killers it's just that people
that have serial killer Tendencies end
up in those jobs because that's and I
kind of feel like people that are serial
killers they really really want to be
truckers because it seems like you get
to work yeah on your own for a lot of
the time and it's like you're out on the
highways and it's like nobody's watching
you and nobody really knows where you
are and nobody really knows where you
are at any given time and it's like
you're probably coming through
jurisdictions right and so I kind of
feel like that's like the ideal yeah
thing for like somebody that wants to do
that because like I said they can just
pick up somebody like that's hitchhiking
or something and kill them and dump them
in the next state and no one will even
find them or even know who they are
you're committing a crime you pick up a
girl in one jurisdiction commit the
crime on the way and then drop her off
in another jurisdiction you don't live
in any three jurisdictions so you're
just not a suspect if they don't see you
so before DNA there would be no way to
link no way to believe and the thing
about it is that they can really only
they can only link you if they know like
once they found the DNA they can only
link your DNA if you've already been
arrested for something else and like
your DNA is already in your fail you
know what I mean yeah the only the only
[__] in your armor would be they have
to get the DNA they have to have your
DNA one
or at least some of your relatives DNA
which that's shit's happening then they
have to get whatever DNA you left on
that body which means that they need
that body
yeah so
that's the only way you could be caught
is if they get that body and there's DNA
on it
and I'd imagine that's pretty rare for
something like that happening most of
the bodies there's no DNA on them well
yeah I mean well the thing about it
particularly in the cases of like Texas
Killing Fields and stuff like that is
that sometimes those victims weren't
found until much much later so they were
generally just like skeletons skeletons
yeah so you know you're not gonna get
here
skeleton I mean sometimes you can get it
off the clothes and everything like that
like they've gotten a lot better with it
but
and I think they did actually like solve
a couple of those cases but the thing
about it is like they're doing it you
know ever since uh [__] D'Angelo the
Golden State killer got caught they've
been doing a lot of Cold Case DNA [__]
because a lot of cases that I wrote
about like in my book like I'll go back
to you know see if there's updates and a
lot of those have been solved like even
if they haven't been solved at least
they've identified like a lot of um the
victims that were unidentified for like
30 40 years they actually are going back
and trying to solve all of these cases
which I thought was like actually really
cool that they have people doing that
I'm trying to put myself in old boys
shoes here you are you're a truck driver
or something like that you got a normal
job
and you got a string of seven or eight
crimes behind you these bodies out there
all right that you've [__] stashed
and you're thinking about
man if they find one of those bodies and
there's DNA on it they're gonna [__]
dick might be able to find me how how do
you [__] sleep at night
I know it's like to me worried the whole
[__] time that man no matter what you
know what I mean I'd be worried I'd be
looking over my shoulder thinking man
[__] man I might be in bed here and
[__] boom then all of a sudden
they're into they're gonna bust in here
yeah and then they got they're like we
got you for the murder of this and that
oh [__] so
you would think that you couldn't live a
normal life you constantly be worried
but maybe they just maybe there's just
so much overconfidence in them or
they'll never catch me that kind of
thing I kind of feel like that might be
the case like with some of them because
they do seem like
well I don't know I guess it depends on
the type because look at somebody like
BTK yeah who he obviously thought he was
smarter he's the smartest [__]
the cops were required to tell the truth
because they're they're the good guys I
was laughing man that was hilarious
that was hilarious that he actually
thought that's how that's how he got
caught now be honest if I sent you the
disc he won't be able to track me will
you oh no absolutely
okay all right thank you he thought the
cops are his friends and that they and
that they had to tell him the truth he's
an idiot
he's what
that's the worst they were working
together that's the worst kind of idiot
is the idiot that thinks they're smart
yeah
he
with the cops cops that was something
else man that's Jesus Christ
but yeah I I think a lot of times I
don't know it seems like they don't
worry about it maybe they just maybe
they're sociopaths and they just don't
care yeah maybe or maybe like you said
they're just so overconfidence they
won't catch me they just like they don't
worry about oh they're stupid they'll
never catch me yeah they're stupid yeah
which is funny because don't ever find
those bodies I got them hidden too good
they'll never find them
yeah it's it's or maybe it's just maybe
all of them you know they all of them
are all options depends on whatever the
guy is yeah some of them think that you
know they never can other guys be like I
don't care if they do catch me you know
it's just yeah I think it's like a
combination though
[Laughter]
uh Linex Warrior said come on 13 o'clock
family crew and subscribers 31 in the
chat only 19 likes hit that like button
folks yeah get the algorithm jumping
yeah you probably should because and of
course super chats are active bro super
chats are active and if you're listening
to the show uh recorded uh you could
leave Jenny a super thanks this is a new
feature and even the super thanks are
active on all the old videos too yeah so
uh even though you're not listening to
an old video see you're not getting this
message
I went better there bro you did first I
was traveling through space time
talking to the Past
[Laughter]
Jason S says Henry Lucas only killed his
mum I think but confessed over 300
murders yeah I'm pretty sure uh Henry
Lee Lucas only killed maybe two people
maybe three Albert Fish is a little
suspect too and he did kill a bunch of
people and ate that little girl that
[__] he did do he put all that weird
[__] into his body those needles and
everything yeah
but he also confessed to to crimes that
didn't have a body or a case to match
with that thank you very much
like he said he killed that little black
boy by beating him to death and and he
says because no one would ever miss him
type of deal
I don't believe that's true they found a
[__] little dead black boy there that
they would have recorded it so we found
a little dead black boy over here who
did this that's what you know the cops
would record that
so there was no little
um body found I think he made a lot I
think Albert Fish was into making
himself
suffer as much as possible because he
liked to make himself suffer
putting needles in himself and trying to
be his super freak he thought he was
Jesus and the devil simultaneously and
he wanted him he wanted himself to be
as repulsive and as evil as possible in
the eyes of other people so he made up
crimes
to make himself sound even worse but he
did eat that little girl although he
said I didn't [__] her though she died a
virgin oh you
thank you bro yeah she cried and cried
when I told her I was gonna way to clear
that way low bar yeah yeah yeah she
cried and cried
yeah like I'd have to beat that dude to
death man I'm sorry
I mean yeah I'd take that home I think
probably probably most people would do
the same thing most people would help
you it's like here hand me a hammer my
greatest fear is that it would [__]
go down too quickly he was kind of frail
looking
I don't want to stretch that [__] out
man I might want to do that Mongolian
[__] death coffin [__] treatment I
mean if anybody deserves it the thing is
though is that that dude was such a
masochist he'd probably enjoy it yeah he
probably enjoy anything you did to him
because he would just soak up pain
yeah so you you couldn't win yeah yeah
uh thank you Victor for the Super Chat
post the show schedule for all the shows
on social media so I can get back on
track okay I if I remember I will do
that
mostly we're just down to three wait a
minute four live streams a week we do a
movie review on Sunday at six
and then we do a haunting Mondays on
Monday obviously at 7 30. then we do the
main show on Wednesday at 7 30 and then
we do Side Tracks Friday night at 7 30.
and then I've been trying to do a video
a week
um but you know
like I'm trying to do one book review
one movie review like I'm trying to do
something for scare Salon I'm trying to
do something for Crime Memorial it's you
know I'm working full-time now so it's
like really really hard for me to get
[__] done but I am trying to keep up on
this stuff but we are we have been doing
all the live streams though
Celtic Angel 73 said another movie
suggestion don't go to sleep is a very
good made for TV movie from the early
1980s with Dennis Weaver Valerie Harper
and Ruth Gordon there are a couple
uploads of it on YouTube you know I
don't think that I've ever heard of that
but man that's a good cast I'm gonna
have to like check that out okay so
thanks for that recommendation Victor
said okay I wrote it down uh Larry and
creatures and what books have you
written Jenny I'm a Noob here
um I've written like a bunch of fiction
and a bunch of non-fiction like I did a
true crime Trilogy called The Faceless
villain volume one two and three
and those are what we'll do commercials
before we shut down and you'll and we'll
do the commercials for the books you
have those don't you well I already did
those yeah yeah so don't worry about it
don't worry about them but um but yeah
so uh anyway so it's like that's all
unsolved murders from the 20th century
like the first one is like 50 years and
then it's like 20 years and 20 years and
then I did like a bunch of paranormal
ones like I did one called the Unseen
hand that's all Poltergeist cases Steve
Mara books and then I did one a couple
with Steve Mara yeah uh the Rossdale
Poltergeist we talked about that case
that he was on and uh the one with fire
Whispers yeah
Keith Linder uh yeah he because Steve
marrow worked on that case he's a
parapsychologist and I did a case with
it like a book with him about that we
wrote a book about his case called
Mammoth Mountain Poltergeist yeah it's
got good reviews everybody loves it it's
true it had
and I also have
um some fiction books I wrote like two
books of short stories like horror
stories one's called the associated
villainies and the other one is called
hopeful monsters then I wrote a couple
of novels uh one's called bread Menace
one is called the five poisons and one
is called Bellwether and Tammy said
don't forget the cookbook yeah that's
right we also have a cookbook that's on
that's actually all the other books are
the ones I just mentioned are on Amazon
The cookbook I think is only on Lulu
they might have it on Amazon
too A lot of people bought it
yeah yeah we did a cookbook well because
we keep we well we kept like getting
sidetracked and talking about food so
everybody said oh you guys should cook
yeah so we did
[Laughter]
Southern Classics it's got Mexican food
how to make Mexican food from scratch
um what else is it got Italian it's got
um a bunch of American food American
food is like the meat because there's
like a lot of southern food in there
yeah there's a little bit of Brazilian
food yeah some Brazilian food got that
in there so my favorite Brazilian
recipes Indian Thai yeah yeah and
Chinese yep all the Chinese fast foods
got some recipes of that in there
because Tom Cooks all the things I cook
all that he cooks all the things does it
have grits yes it does yes it does
yeah we did a little section there's a
little section of this says what the
[__] are grits yeah
and I dictated most of the book to Jenny
and if you read the [__] it sounds like
me talking [__] everybody well because
it is YouTube yeah well I mean
essentially like I kind of made it into
like sort of proper sentences and stuff
but that's how we wrote the book is that
we just had I was just like here's the
recipe like talk about you know what
this Nana put in yeah yeah and so like
he would just talk about and I recorded
him talking and then like I uh you know
transcribed it yeah and like put it into
it came out good it was fun to do we
were I was drinking
I was dictating out what to do it's kind
of like I felt like I was talking to
hundreds of people yeah it's you know it
felt good
[Laughter]
and you had me recording it yeah
I was sitting there drinking I'm talking
to all you [__] the next thing you
know you never ever ever
let a banana puddy turn brown
it's just whatever was off top of my
head at the time yeah I am a a trade
cook
um I was trained by some [__]
absolutely fantastic chefs on the
Mississippi Gulf Gulf Coast that's
really where I learned a lot of a lot of
the [__] you know real cooking
make a sauces I used to make I was one
of one of the jobs I had in there was to
make salad dressing
make salad dressing yeah and make
ketchup make [__] um uh barbecue
sauce that Chef would not buy anything
everything had to be exclusive to that
restaurant
that's a good idea yeah making blue
cheese dressing you know making [__]
Green Goddess making [__] um
oh a special kind of Blended fitted
vinaigrette what was that [__]
vinaigrette you had to [__] blend the
[__]
uh vinegar and oil together I forgot
what it was called and it would come out
yellow and it would not the oil and
vinegar would not separate it would it
would hold together in suspension
forever it's beautiful
making remoulade there's another one
that we used to do
and making all the desserts
I also did line cook stuff deep frying
uh deep frying Seafood uh ran Grill
um salads I was in all the positions I
started off in a dish pit washing dishes
as a kid in high school grandpars
remembers it he remembers where I used
to work in high school when I was over
in Michigan at that time
that's why I started started wash as
washing dishes
and then I ended up in the kitchen
well this the dish Pit's in the kitchen
but you know as a cook
Victor said if y'all have a book on hand
I'll literally buy it right now if you
autograph it and send it to me uh do we
have one in here I have one but I don't
know where it went
it's in here somewhere we can get
another coffee yeah we can get another
copy because I've had that one for a
while that's like an old one this one no
that's not it
I probably it's probably back there like
behind the on the desk there behind Tom
savini
or under BTK
under BTK like you know there's there's
some books that they're he's right there
in front of your face isn't he
oh yeah BTK yeah see okay don't make me
think I'm crazy
foreign
creature said I love savini yeah that's
got Tom savini back there
he kind of looks like my dad my dad kind
of looked like that when he was younger
I swear to God it was back there Victor
said how much
how much were we charging for that how
much they I have to check and see how
much they are on Lulu because I don't
remember
I thought they were about 30 weren't
they something like that
because they're hot it's a hardback yeah
it's a hardback yeah let me go get hold
on just keep me occupied and get my life
I'm sure it's back there
I'm pretty sure because there's just
like books right under where BTK is
he's sitting on top of like some books
and I'm pretty sure because I think that
um
because I designed the cookbook for the
vegan black metal Chef also he has a
cookbook called The Satanic spell book
like but seitan like that that meat
substitute it's spelled like that
um so yeah I just I designed his uh
cookbook and I have a copy of that over
there too
mango said uh I met savini great guy
yeah see I told you it was over there
oh thank you Victor
he sent us fifty dollars for the
cookbook oh you'll love it show it there
we go see it's hardcover yeah it's hard
back
and look the kitties aren't as large
Beijing and Pookie out in front
helping us out
yeah we got all kind of what we got
refried beans
I can't really see so you gotta do it
laughs
yeah see
it's fun
I mean we wanted to make it like even if
you didn't make anything that was in
there we still want to make it like fun
to read you know what I mean yeah and
[Music]
um
it's all in the in um
it's not in metric it's in the American
system well I think I put I think I put
um conversions okay for most things
okay yeah he said I dm'd you my address
on Facebook okay I mean this is just the
copy I've had this for a while but it's
it's Mitch it's in good good condition
we haven't I haven't taken it we'll just
get another one so yeah so we'll just uh
sign up matter of fact this was this was
the sample copy wasn't it
yeah so this is actually the first one
ever made yeah I think this is the one
that I actually like ordered for the
thing yep like to proof it yep but uh
yeah so we can sign it and I can uh get
it mailed out to you in a couple of days
yeah yeah
Larry and creature said
um some of my favorite Horrors are
savini stuff Martin oh that's a great
movie I love that movie uh maniac and
deranged yeah deranged we did a um
that's the one that's kind of based on
Ed Gein right
we just did we just reviewed that one
not too long ago that was an excellent
movie from the 1970s
that was I think one of the first ones
that he worked on Victor says yay did
you do the photography as well I did not
I bought you brought these photos
because we didn't we don't really have
the um the photo
I don't really have like a good enough
camera to like take really nice photos
the thing is and the lighting in here do
not want to photograph food unless
you're a [__] professional right the
photographs of the food that's not food
because we yeah like we thought about it
but I was like I don't think they're
gonna come out that good no so I'm just
gonna buy some no
but they show a photograph of the ice
cream or a photograph of uh sour cream
no that's Crisco you know what I mean
some of the soups that's not soup uh
some that's paint you know it's not food
that they're taking pictures of [__]
food does not photograph well it really
doesn't it's a whole art to that you
want to leave that up to the
professionals so you can just if you
have a professional service that [__]
is offering
products like photographs of food you
can find any recipe there they got a
photograph of anything that looks like
that and you go yeah okay that'll work
yeah I found pretty much yeah right
because I I pay a lot of money for like
that stuff subscription so yeah but the
recipes are
they're either very traditional recipes
if it's a southern traditional or uh
some of it's family recipe yes we'll see
but yeah
it's super fun so uh so yeah I will get
that because I have all the stuff here
to like I can mail it from the house
yeah we can weigh things and mail things
we got mail sir this is this is a
business it's on office
so yeah I sent out and if uh if Amanda
is here I sent out your shirt this
morning
like they came and picked it up yeah I
[__] up I brought it back in I thought
it was a delivery I know I came home
from work yesterday morning and like the
package was like sitting on my chair I'm
like I told you I was like I love this
this was going out oh I said I
specifically told you I showed it to him
and I said man man I'm putting this out
by the front door don't [__] with it
because it's going out I don't listen
okay oh man and then I come home from
working it sitting in my chair I was
like they were putting a new roof on the
house and I [__] had to go around and
clear everything out because they had
all this equipment they're throwing
shingles and [__] uh so I was in a panic
and I just pulled it I thought that was
mail coming in
because I mean we did have other
packages that came in like some of like
pookies treats and stuff yeah Pookie
don't eat the furniture yeah she chews
everything she's eating the furniture
all right
so I wish I could she looked at me like
what's wrong okay she gave him a look
like what happened oh she ran she's like
no she just went she just ran right
there oh I was gonna put Pokey come here
Pokey come here come here Paul she's
like a little bit no I don't want to be
out of here
come on little Furniture eater she's
shaking her head no no no she shakes her
head no she's like no no no yeah she's
like no no
yeah yeah it's all good
she's uncomfortable up here she's like I
don't like being on camera poor Pokey
she was like so scared because when the
roofers came yeah because they were
making so much noise yeah like Tom was
messaging me and I was at work and it's
like Pookie's hiding under the bed like
you're freaking out I don't need to bed
for two days she's like oh my God
yeah okay
um all right so I guess we've been going
for two hours and 15 minutes and it's
almost 10 and I have to get up very
early yeah from the
um airport tomorrow that's right and uh
we will not have a Friday show probably
probably we're gonna do it on Saturday
we'll do it on Saturday then she comes
home from work she's immediately gotta
get ready for the club and we're all
going to the club yeah Sophie's been on
the show before she wants to do uh uh a
show with us on Saturday we're gonna do
a side track on Saturday with show soap
um don't be diameter and messenger and
flirting with her like last time last
time sending her money and [__] well I
don't know if it was y'all specifically
but she's pretty okay and he's scared
Y'all Scared her off she didn't want to
come back on anymore she's very shy
great
but uh no she's gonna have fun she's
she's not as shy as she was she's 30 now
so she's not a kid like she was but yeah
she'll be here tomorrow night so yeah so
yeah so Sidetrack show we'll do the
Sidetrack show on Saturday because like
I said we're going to mannequins Friday
night and it's like I gotta work all day
so I don't get home till six and I have
to come home and get ready and then
we're gonna go out so we'll do a side
tracks on Saturday maybe we'll do it
earlier we'll do it like at six
maybe so then that way
I don't know we'll think about it but
I'll announce it like before pain anyway
mango said we was all well behaved yeah
yeah Megan remembers her yeah Tammy's
saying yay so yeah she's fine I'm glad
we're gonna uh I'm glad she's coming
yeah she is third time she's visited
she's missed us and uh she hasn't seen
the new house yet yeah that's right it's
snowing in Michigan so she's she lost
power she was charging up her phone to
[__] send me text messages because
she was packing when they lost power and
she couldn't charge her phone she had to
go to the car and charge her phone which
is crazy because it was back on because
in Florida today it was 85 [__]
degrees Yeah she's [__] sending me
pictures away outside her window and
it's [__] ice and [__] sleet and
[__] coming down that's crazy I remember
Michigan I went out to like eat some
lunch in my car like in the parking lot
I'm like oh my God I'm sweating my balls
off out here it's 85 [__] degrees and
it's February yeah [__] Florida
anyway all right so we will see you guys
again Victor I will get your book sent
out uh in a day or two so be on the
lookout for that and we'll see you guys
again on Saturday I'll announce what
time it is we'll probably do it like a
little bit earlier because we're gonna
go out afterward so hopefully Sophie
will do the show with us and that'll be
super fun so thanks everybody for
dropping by thanks for your super chats
and we will see you guys again this
weekend good